welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is TL Cowen who is a writer performer
activist and a professor she is
currently at Yale as the Canadian
Bicentennial visiting lecturer and
digital humanities fellow her academic
work focuses on the cultural and
intellectual economies and social lives
of trans feminist and queer grassroots
performance today we'll talk with
Professor Cohen about her research on
feminist and queer cabaret welcome
professor Kailyn hi thanks for having me
you are welcome it is delightful for us
to have you here today your work is very
interesting let's talk about the chapter
you recently contributed to an anthology
yeah tell us about it okay well it's a
very exciting anthology it's edited by
Allison Campbell and Stephen Ferrier and
it's called queer dramaturg is where
performance leads queer and it's an
anthology that is I think one of my kind
of most exciting contributions in terms
of the Emilio that I'm being published
in and so it's it's a collection of
different perspectives on queer
performance from really around the world
and it's one of the very very I think
rare collections that really does look
at many different places in the world
and one queer performance is happening
and so my my chapter which has a very
long title which is something like a
hybrid present embody I'd cabaret
methods and I think activist performance
and I'm looking at two performances in
particular the performance of season or
NICUs from Mexico City in his
performance it's called Joe Pesci honest
de la chingada and the performance
called Lee demi-monde which is
alexandre de gloire and who's from
toronto and so my work is really an
exploration of hemispheric performance
studies in particular on transgender
feminist and queer cabaret performance
and by cabaret I mean the kind of
political satirical adult-oriented
variety show and so both enriquez and
Taylor make political cabaret and and so
the article chapter is making an
argument for the ways that the cabaret
performance seems to be a structure
that's kind of a uniquely conducive to
critical citizenship to political
expression and to bringing audiences
around to the idea of social change so
what led you to be interested in this
topic well I guess first and foremost I
am a participant of these cabaret
cultures and so I have been a performer
working in cabaret since the 1990s and
I've lived in a lot of different cities
and I've performed in a lot of different
cities and I have been an audience
member of cabaret in a lot of different
cities and you know really over the last
20 years I have seen just such
remarkable similarity in cabaret
performance in different locales so
there's something very similar between
the cabaret that's in Vancouver Toronto
Montreal New York the Twin Cities Los
Angeles San Francisco Mexico City and in
particular i'm looking at north america
and and so i have been working on this
boat project called sliding scale which
is on cabri cultures primarily in
Montreal New York in Mexico City but
kind of more broadly across North
America and I I guess my interest in the
project is really to consider what is it
about cabaret that is so
to so many of these can politically
engaged feminist and queer performance
artists and also to the audiences like
it remains an incredibly political
vibrant popular form in these
communities in ways that it's not in the
mainstream and so that's really what I'm
kind of looking at when I'm okay
studying cabaret let's talk about some
of the similarities yes of course okay
so really what you see a lot of is you
see kind of structural similarities so
the variety show structure you have a
master of ceremony or in in the French
we say coffee acconci and you have a
master of ceremonies that will kind of
bring the audience together and
introduce the theme of the show and
often the theme of the show has
something to do with a kind of political
theme so it could be on kind of
transgender awareness in feminist
communities for example is something
that cabaret might be and then you have
lots of different kinds of performers so
someone might be doing a burlesque dance
someone might be doing stand-up comedy
someone might be doing spoken word
performance there might be some video
there might be someone playing piano
there could be some you know modern
dance and what happens is that there's a
range of expertise there's a you know
the performers range in age and and some
of them are very very polished
performers in some are very amateur and
audiences are as diverse as what's
happening on stage and you also one of
the other really important similarities
is the kind of media that is kind of
attached to to cabaret in feminist and
queer communities and so you see you
know very similar kinds of posters very
similar kinds of really kind of
under-resourced documentation so it's
very it's an ephemeral form that doesn't
have a lot
its own archives and you also see the
way that cabaret gets promoted is really
through word of mouth through posters in
kind of community bookstores when those
still existed and you know bars coffee
shops people will hand around flyers
oftentimes cabarets will get promoted at
big parties so if you're doing cabaret
you'll go to a party and you'll
circulate at some other place and even
to the point of like these very
ingenious ways that people promote their
cabaret really deeply within a community
is for example in for the meow Mix
cabaret that a wonderful cabaret
producer and curator mia hamm's in the
ca what she would do when she was
starting her first queer women's cabaret
in montreal in the early 1990s she
advertised it in the women seeking women
personal ads and so it's you know it's
like it's very much about you know
what's happening on stage what's
happening in the audience but also
what's happening kind of broadly within
the community and how cabaret kind of
brings that all together here's a
question do they ever use social media
oh my god yes of course yes and in fact
it's I have to say that with the with
the popularity of something like
Facebook you gain a lot and and in fact
Facebook has become the kind of de facto
archive for a lot of these
community-based ephemeral forms and so
that's really cool so the Facebook page
can stay up after the event and people
can upload their photos and things like
that and so that's really great and you
can invite thousands of people with one
click rather than you know 50 people
with 50 of lawyers at a bar you know
much easier it's easier but it also
loses that kind of face-to-face intimacy
of some of the previous ways of a
mediating these these cabaret so it's
super great Facebook for example and
Twitter are great for you know
for promoting but it has really
transformed the way that carry functions
within communities yes okay one of the
things you say that the Cabaret is a
trans local phenomena yes so what do you
mean by that okay so hands local you've
heard of transnational which is across
countries in the trans local is very
similar and certainly related to the
idea of the transnational but the trends
local references the multi-directional
circulation of ideas and people between
locations in ways that doesn't
necessarily prioritize the nation or the
national in in the way that those bodies
circulates so it could be trans local
could be for example studying cabaret
across Vancouver Montreal Toronto and
Edmonton so that's within a country but
I'm looking at how this form works in
these multiple locations and really
thinking about cabaret itself as the
phenomenon that moves rather than people
necessarily moving across those spaces
and so you think about the cadbury
structure so this variety structure that
remains very much intact across these
places even though the performers
themselves are not moving but then I
also in looking at Mexico City Montreal
and New York and while each of those
places have Kemp arrays that differ
slightly the kinds of particularity xin
characteristics of the cabaret in each
of those places has a lot to do with the
cities that they're in as well as the
countries that they're in and so talking
about the trans local is a way to kind
of nuanced those kinds of
characteristics and those particular era
T's in a way that the transnational
doesn't necessarily
so you chose Mexico City and Toronto for
the bookshop exactly why is that because
I saw these two performances so Cesaro
nica's is a doozy Cascione de la
chingada and Alexander tagged Lars lay
demi-monde and I could not believe how
their use of what I call a
trans-temporal embodiment it's one of
those you know kind of incredibly dense
phrases that I use in this article but
trans-temporal embodiment what I'm
talking about is the way that both and
ricas and tickle are perform these
figural figure figures figural figures
these mythological figures so in the
case of Andrea cos he's performing
legendado which is a very kind of common
and popularly used figure in Mexico to
refer to the kind of feminized Mexican
pneus in the kind of emerges through
colonialization invasive Spanish
colonialization of colonization of
Mexico so you have letting gotta and
then you have the figure that tickler is
performing which is prostitution herself
and both of these performers talk about
i'm going to call i'm just going to say
oppressive relations of power so in
Enrique's this case he's talking about
spanish colonialism US imperialism and
narco culture particularly as is a kind
of ongoing way that Mexico is kind of
being undermined and and and kind of
experiencing violence at the hands of
these different kind of formations of
power and the way that tickle our talks
about she uses prostitution herself to
look at the ways that the role of the
sec
worker has been used as a cultural trope
in you know it from everything from like
lat ovata to the police's Roxanne to
pretty woman so you have the image of
the sex worker who that gets used to
build these and fictional narratives
that become very kind of sensational and
popular and people get very famous like
Julie Roberts is very famous for playing
these roles whereas people who are sex
workers in real life remain criminalized
remain targets for police and other
violence and so both of these performers
having never seen each other never heard
about each other are doing something
very similar in the way that they're
tracing these kind of political
structures and experiences of negative
relations of power negative experiences
of power through long histories on the
stage using humor using kind of body
dancing using video using you know all
sorts of other things but they both do
this right interesting and a you know
part of what you write about is activism
that comes out of cabaret so let's talk
about a couple of specific examples
about that okay well I mean both of the
the performers that I talk about in this
essay are really doing activist
performance and by activism what I what
I mean is sometimes it's very explicit
like sometimes you'll have a performer
get up on stage into a political rant
about about an issue that's important to
them and then and so that's you know one
form of activism on stage in cabaret but
then you also have performances that are
activists in a way that's like slightly
more subtle and what these performances
do is they draw audience's attention to
political problem or issue and kind of
model away and
what they do is they model an analysis
of this political issue or political
problem in a way that allows us to think
about the possibility for social change
and so for example just in the case of
Alexandra ticklers piece for example one
of the things that lead Amanda me moan
does by the end of the hour or so of
this this performance that has many
different episodes in it many different
scenes or skits by the end of that by
the end of that performance the audience
really thinks oh you know I may be an
really thought about what it means to be
criminalized as a sex worker and what it
means to have the thing that you're
doing as work B also making you a target
for incarceration and other kinds of fun
of legal procedures and and so then in
in Canada for example that kind of
activism created an opportunity for
popular understanding of the importance
of decriminalizing sex work and so in
Canada sex work was decriminalized and
then recrimination so but this kind of
work not only just its activists in the
way that it builds a kind of a built-in
understanding across audiences and then
you know if you were to see that show
for example you might go home and say to
your partner or to your mother you know
I saw this performance and I never
really thought about this but I'm going
to think about it some more so I think
that's really the way that that cabaret
functions in an activist way and there's
a famous line from Friedrich colander
who is a great kappa reddest from the
rhymer area of era of Germany and he
talks about the Cabaret functioning in a
political way as I'm serving you a
poison cookie so you'll be watching this
I kind of kind of innocuous performance
it's entertaining you're laughing maybe
a-and you're not really thinking that
you're being taught something that
you're being asked to think and then all
of a sudden there'll be some kind of he
talks about a political show so or
there'll be some element that that kind
of gets you thinking and then you don't
even really realize that it's happened
until three days later when you think oh
I think I digested something that made
me think right and so that's the way
that I think cavalry functions as as
activism okay so what what do you
conclude in your piece I I conclude just
that that first of all you know I think
cabaret gets undermined as a cultural
formation because it's often very
amateur and it happens not in grand
theaters but in bookstores and in you
know kind of like home basements and
backyards and and but yeah it's doing
some very important cultural work and
then it does create possibilities for
social change and for thinking about the
possibilities for social change so
rather than rather than thinking that
things always have to be the way they
are cabaret allows us to kind of imagine
or hope for shifting and in the way
things are okay yeah very good thank you
so much for being thank you very much
for some of your research for more
information about professor Cowan enter
work please visit our website at
macmillan report yale edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale